ne ratez pas
en tournée dans toute la france lors à
l'aune d'un spectacle d'humour qui
traitent de sujets hilarant à les
attentats les génocides l'avortement et
les métiers qui mettent leurs dissidents
les enfants laura l'eau les journalistes
sont unanimes c'est ce qu'on a lu ce que
je ne tolère pas ce type d'humour je
suis désespéré l'oral home
les critiques sont fine et pertinente
labels les plus grands humoristes
s'arrachent ses talents j'adore lors
alone quel artiste génial d'ailleurs
elle met beaucoup en la création du
nouveau spectacle
elle s'occupe des enfants cachés au
bureau elle fait le ménage elle fait la
cuisine elle décortique même les
pistaches à l'heure de l'apéro ses
parents sont hyper fier
oui nous sommes très fiers car nous
avons une deuxième fille qui elle est à
ok tu l'auras lawn le public est sous le
charme
[Musique]
laure alone leur alone elle est où je
fais la butte et je vais la butée bas on
n'a encore rien dit il a donc autant
pour moi oui bon bah ça va cette
percutant c'est original c'est très très
drôle mais surtout c'est différent c'est
ça la grande grande force de ce
spectacle c'est pour ça que les gens
parlent de génie les longs qui sort du
spectacle 10 c'est du génie
ah bah enfin du positif les gens disent
le spectacle de jérémy ferrari
c'est du génie il en légende des saints
lors à l'aune dé la butte et un
spectacle tous les genres sortent
complètement
oui ils ressortent complètement et c'est
déjà pas mal
[Musique]
et
1 aura 12 avril d'accord mais j'avais
pas compris le la question non bah oui
alors leur alone spectacle
non mais non c'est pareil à donner en
spectacle